ich heiße martin schumann ich bin 64
jahre alt in hamburg geboren und
aufgewachsen bin jetzt alleinerziehender
vater von drei kindern
die sind im alter von knapp fünf jahren
zehn jahren und 13 jahren
ich bin jetzt pensioniert im ruhestand
nicht so doll drücken die zeit im moment
empfinde ich als ziemlich belastend wenn
ferien sind dann habe ich die kinder
auch ununterbrochen aber dann
unternehmen wir was machen wir urlaub
jetzt sind die kinder seit mittlerweile
ich glaube sieben wochen zu hause weil
er vorher die frühjahrs zu jenen waren
und ich kann mit diesen kindern nichts
unternehmen die spielplätze sind
geschlossen
kann mich dann eben halt wirklich nur
darauf konzentrieren die kleinste zu
bespaßen und ja dass die sache hier den
laden am laufen zu lassen so um es mal
ganz salopp zu sagen
das heißt putzen waschen bügeln kochen
einkaufen am schulunterricht ist da
überhaupt nicht zu denken ich muss die
lehrkräfte wirklich sehr loben die geben
sich alle mühe und ich hatte auch schon
gespräche mit ihm geführt hat sind sie
natürlich auch verpflichtet sie sind
teilweise beamte sie müssen ihrem
lehrauftrag nachkomme das machen die
sehr gut mein e-mail-postfach ist voll
mit mails ich bekomme post mit
unterlagen aber ich bin einfach nicht in
der lage das umzusetzen
es ist nicht möglich die kinder hier zu
hause zu unterrichten
und wenn könnte ich es nur mit einem
kind ich möchte mich konzentriert mit
diesem kind hinsetzen das ist einfach
nicht machbar
das habe ich auch so den lehrkräften
schon mitgeteilt ich kann es noch nicht
mal im ansatz und aus diesem grunde ich
versuche es noch nicht mal ich hatte
folgende idee dazu dieses halbjahr muss
einfach als verloren erklärt werden
es kann vielleicht in die
schulgeschichte eingehen als das corona
halbjahr
passiert das nicht werden sehr viele
kinder auf der strecke bleiben vielfach
kinder die sowieso schon in prekären
verhältnissen leben
das wäre schade